do ter de made a token attempt to
increase capacity by building a mega
rehab facility on a military base about
four hours north of manila our crew is
the first ever to be allowed inside to
film
it's a big complex divided into four
four phases each face can occupy a
maximum of two thousand five hundred
patients i know no other centres in the
world that has the same capacity or the
same logistical needs not entirely sugar
this has been reinforced it i mean the
whole thing is just they're doing their
best but this is held together very
seriously to say the least
better reconsider going up the stairs
that they seemed at first the entire
structure is just kind of floating
Christ they build this in three months
they know they're solving and three on
the in three months yeah these are all
prefab expect that this is a temporary
facility that the end of the day when
the facilities are no longer needed
they can be given to the military for
whatever personal dimension deem it
necessary 60s Danny
then don't have it could be six years is
the length of the president's term right
yeah just pick that number on it and it
then Aaron that its up its up to the
next administration want to continue
with
so on one hand a 10,000 bed mega rehab
facility is undoubtedly a good thing
especially when compared to the violent
alternatives but on the other it's a
patchwork solution it's it's a band-aid
and they said as much
they're building it on the fly kind of
popsicle sticks and chewing gum even at
full capacity this facility will only
address the needs of a few for every
addict admitted there are still a
hundred on the streets fearing for their
lives